- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is talk about a relatively
recent U.S. Supreme Court case,
and this is the United
States versus Lopez,
and the decision was made in 1995.
And this is significant
because many of the cases
we have talked about are things
that broadened the power
of the federal government.
While the decision in
United States versus Lopez,
which was a split decision, it
was a five-to-four decision,
put some limits on federal power.
And so just to understand what happened.
In 1990, the U.S. Congress passes
the Gun-Free School Zones Act of 1990.
And it says, "It shall be
unlawful for any individual
"knowingly to possess a firearm at a place
"that the individual
knows, or has reasonable
"cause to believe, is a school zone."
And in 1992, a high school student in
San Antonio, Texas, Alfonzo Lopez,
carries a concealed firearm
into his high school.
He is arrested, and then
he is eventually prosecuted
under the Gun-Free School Zones
Act of 1990, a federal law.
And he is tried in a federal court.
His lawyers say, "Hey,
this is unconstitutional.
"The federal government does not have
"the right to regulate whether someone
"carries a gun into a school or not."
While the federal government says,
"Hey, yes we can do this because
"look at the United States Constitution.
"We, the federal government, have a right
"to regulate interstate trade."
And remember what McCullouch
versus Maryland told us.
From the necessary and proper clause,
anything that is a means to regulate,
say, another enumerated
power, like the power
to regulate interstate trade, that is
also constitutional for
the federal government.
But then, you could imagine,
Lopez's lawyers said,
"Hold on a second, that is
a very tenuous connection.
"If you're trying to connect the notion
"of firearms in schools and school safety,
"to interstate commerce,
well you could connect
"almost anything to interstate commerce,
"which would mean that
between the necessary
"and proper clause, the implied powers
"and the enumerated powers of
regulated interstate commerce,
"well then the federal government
"could just regulate anything."
And so it eventually gets appealed
all the way to the United
States Supreme Court.
And in a split five-to-four decision,
the United States Supreme Court
decides in favor of Lopez,
that the Gun-Free School
Zones Act of 1990,
at least as it was originally written,
was indeed unconstitutional, that it's
an overreach of federal power.
And to appreciate the majority's thinking,
here's an excerpt of the
decision by William Rehnquist
who was the Chief Justice
and who was in the majority
and he wrote, "To uphold the
government's contentions here,"
the contention that the
government is making
that it is constitutional to regulate
the possession of firearms in a school,
"we have to pile inference upon inference
"in a manner that would
bid fair to convert
"congressional authority
under the Commerce Clause
"to a general police power of the
"sort retained by the states."
So Rehnquist is saying,
"Hey look, if we say
"that the regulation of
firearms is connected
"to interstate commerce somehow,
"because it somehow affects
the economy between states.
"Well then almost anything, if you layer
"pile inference upon
inference, then that would
"give the right to the federal government
"to police almost anything,
a type of police power
"that's generally retained by the states."
"Admittedly, some of our prior cases have
"taken long steps down that road,
"giving great deference
to congressional action."
And you could go all the way back
to McCulloch versus Maryland.
He's saying, "Yeah, the
Supreme Court has ruled
"many times in favor of
the federal government,
"having a broad understanding
of implied powers."
"The broad language in these opinions
"has suggested the possibility
of additional expansion,
"but we decline here to
proceed any further."
So they're drawing the
line in this decision
on the expansion of congressional power.
"To do so would require us to conclude
"that the Constitution's
enumeration of powers
"does not presuppose
something not enumerated,
"and that there never
will be a distinction
"between what is truly national
and what is truly local.
"This we are unwilling to do."
So he's saying, "Hey look, if we took
"the government's side
on this, there's no end.
"There really isn't anything
that the federal government
"can't do, and then there
won't be a distinction
"between what is truly national
and what is truly local."
I'll let you decide, but
it's a fascinating case,
and it's really important
in this discussion
on power between states
and the federal government
because this was a decision
that kind of drew a line
and said, "Okay, we can't
let the federal government
"have an unlimited number of powers
"based on just being able to
tie inference upon inference
"to something like the Commerce Clause."